we had lessons learned
it was a hands-down love at first sight
unsettling familiarities
i feel like i just met my wife
and beautiful new beginning
it's a phenomenal start this is you're
the bachelorette season 16
episode five or should we call it
episode one i don't know
recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rosie
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
and we are having a breath
of fresh
i can't breathe in this thing
i'm tasha i'm here for all of you
oh my gosh are you ready i'm so ready
oh what did we think of this episode of
the bachelorette you guys
i just love love loved it for so many
reasons i can't wait to discuss it tell
me your thoughts
i brought today uh not our usual rose
but a beautiful colorful red
red spilling it instead
of our usual rose i have brought today
a red red wine like a red red rose
because we've got a new rose i'm wearing
a rose shirt are you getting the theme
our new girl is here tasha
is the bachelorette you know what still
a lot happens so maybe we're gonna need
a little more wine
let's get to it hello
tasha surprise so last week we got a
glimpse of tasha
this week we are seeing her meet the
men tasha comes in because we don't have
limo entrances because this is a totally
unprecedented situation like we've never
had in the franchise before we already
had a night one with full limo entrances
for claire crawley the original bachelor
but then an unprecedented pandemic
happened
the coronavirus that shut down
production for the first time the
franchise in your 20-year history so
anyway long story short then we had to
weird this like
love at first sight kind of a love story
come on over claire said that that was
her husband i tell myself
i just met my husband she met my first
night so now we have patient who's the
second bachelorette that's ever happened
in the show's history so another
franchise first we have our second
bachelorette here today
got it okay
so tasia comes in well hello
how stunning did you look everybody the
men
stand for her to enter and of course
who leads the
[Music]
our charge bennett yes he does our
unproblematic
gentlemanly yacht-sailing pure
pellegrino drinking
bennett oh my god yo
the guys are awestruck they are smiling
they are literally shaking over tasha
what did you think
that they were thinking look at their
faces
and let me know in the comments below
she's beautiful
couldn't be better and tasha's welcoming
speech to them
is exactly that welcoming first of all
we gotta have a
bomb summer so cheers to that
and they need it remember they've been
through a lot ups and downs
and a lot of sitting around so much time
sitting around
and wondering and waiting she tells them
thanks for being here
thank you guys for staying here i know
you guys have been through a lot
she says i'm grateful to be here i
cannot
share my gratitude enough and it will be
and i
quote an honor to get to know
you men if you guys give me the honor
to get to know you
and i love that because i do think these
guys feel
as though claire didn't want to get to
know them and as much as i think
men should pursue women you gotta show a
guy you're interested you know they
gotta have a little
confidence booster a little reassurance
too
i want to lean into this and i want you
guys to also lean into it
it's what they needed to hear tasha our
charismatic new leader
let's keep going our beautiful bombshell
of a kind
babe i'm having the best time in my life
a breath of fresh
[Music]
air also unrelated but we're in a good
mood so let's talk about it
bennett gruesome scruff
and cheers to that i love a scruff i
love a bennett
[Music]
he's our scruffy sperry dawning east
coast
king she has an incredible energy it's
contagious and we're all feeling it i
mean wow
she is looking stunning
listen i love the drama of everything
that claire careless we had wild ups and
downs it was a roller coaster i was
absolutely captivated on the edge of my
sleep but now we're just gonna have a
little fun i'm having the best time in
my life
great taste is just amazing
it's just her presence and her energy
i'm so happy
i think because the guys seem so happy
they have a
lightness to them the breath afresh that
is tasha has wafted through the room
lifting them up out of their chairs
literally
i feel i'm getting to know them for the
first time i also literally am learning
some of their names
still for the first time like we got
ivan
i'm going to give this 100 he's talking
to tasha seems great didn't really know
he was here
and we got curly hair dude not a hundo
on his name i'm a weirdo in the
turtleneck you're like who is this guy
but he seems lovely oh but then the
drama is starting because this is the
show we know and love it's the gift that
keeps on giving
and what it is giving us is through the
darkness
coming forth from the night mysteriously
out of the shadows
chris harrison
[Music]
honestly i'm stoked about it yes chris
harrison
the hardest working man in fall
television this season
appears seemingly out of nowhere and
this might be
another franchise first chris
harrison steals tasha
sorry to interrupt your time but uh i
need to borrow you for a second
right it's night one the guys are gonna
steal her
chris harrison steals her and he does it
for a very good reason
something is happening that we'd hoped
for because tasha deserves the best
she's getting a limo arrival of new men
did you really think that that
was the only group of guys you're going
to meet tonight oh my gosh
there's another limo full of men pulling
up right now
don't drink for every new guy
[Music]
hope you guys are ready for a few more
now one of them came in with a little
attitude
spencer so which one of you guys scared
away claire
and he gets the first impression rose
you're a person i want to keep around
and the first kiss from tasha what did
you think of this
i felt that tasha was giving him that
rose just kind of purely on a physical
attraction she kept saying
he's hot he is hot like hot
hot hot and he did have some scruff and
he did look good
but you know i'm okay with that because
what we've come from
is a woman giving the first impression
rose to a man
she called her husband it doesn't feel
like i just met my husband
oh you know the pendulum's swinging
totally just for a he's hot vibe
a hot hot pot he's okay with me
it's different it's fun it's the gift
that keeps him giving
but new guys aside the men who have been
here and been through it they could use
a reprieve and you know
these producers are not inhumane so
tasha cancels the rose ceremony
i'd like to cancel the rose ceremony not
in a
i don't want to talk to you guys way but
in a don't worry no one's going to get
eliminated tonight way
and continue all of our journeys they've
been through so much
oh gosh and then we are getting so much
we are already getting a season
teaser that reminds us that as much as
this is a breath of fresh
as much fun as we're having as hot as
all the people are we are still gonna
get the drama
yes we are getting fights it's not
always easy to see
a wolf in sheep's clothing there are
tears
in a white dress is she getting proposed
to ah
oh okay but things are calming down
we're gonna get back in the swing of
things you know we're just gonna do like
a casual
like first group date or something and
then
chris harrison you should be watching
tasha's first dates
oh he is back he's in a room i know this
is unexpected
in a suit hello bachelor nation alone
there's something that needs to be
addressed talking directly to us
we need to talk about what was one of
the most dramatic turn of events
in bachelorette history
but we learn that he is here to learn is
clairendale's love story too good to be
true
he's here to dissect did claire and dale
have contact
before the show started to get answers
we're gonna get answers to
all of these questions nothing is
typical this season so it's time for the
after the final rose claire and dale
congratulations again thank you claire
and dale
and chris harrison is asking the tough
questions
have we experienced a documented case of
love
at first sight
let me know in the comments below do you
think claire and dale were
love at first sight and we are doing the
field work here on the bachelorette
and claire is here how's it going
so good and she is glowing
is this the ring this is the ring and
she confirms
it was love at first sight was it love
at first sight
absolutely
it's a heart
okay it's good enough i can't draw
better heart that's where we're at
didn't go to art school
hello even more proof dale is here
and he says also love at first
sight was it love at first sight it was
a hands-down
love at first sight
venn diagram you love this man yeah
absolutely
and i tell him that over and over and
over and over again she says it a lot
they showed up here today and
showed up for each other
she says a lot listen okay listen we're
going to try again we're going to try
again all right this is an introductory
course
claire plus dale
equals love at first
sight those are eyes all i've ever
wanted is a man to show up for me
you've done that every single day for me
yeah and you've done
the exact same for me they showed up
here today they showed up for each other
the science is proven but dr chris
harrison is here with another
hypothesis he asks the question that has
been asked a lot and that claire has
repeatedly denied but they did film this
a while ago so he is asking did you two
talk to each other before production
began did you guys communicate
talk neat text anything
before that first night did you lie
to all of baxter nation 100 no
and they say no they do deny that yet
again
and do you guys believe them i do claire
has really stuck to her story on this
i don't think that they were in contact
before the show listen claire says
she just wants people to be happy for
her and dale i just wish people can be
happy for us
she knows that this all happened fast
this whole season has never
these are extraordinary times but this
whole season was unprecedented in a
crazy year
we've never had a pandemic in the past
before and they have a
wild first time it's ever happened love
story dale says he loves claire with
every ounce of his being
and i love her with every ounce of my
being but this is still clear
we're still speeding claire says she
wants babies what is next for you guys
moving in together wedding what's up i
think like you know
obviously babies uh
dale's like we're getting married first
claire's like ha ha whatever
you just skipped right over that yeah
you just can't fit in with it no
we are we having babies first we're
gonna get married first yeah we're gonna
get married first
whatever happened what did you think of
the after the final rose
let me know in the comments below oh
babes or should i say
babies babies babies
you guys i had to come and do a quick
vlog on that moment because
i have been thinking about it all night
if claire and dale want to get
married and have babies in whatever
order they should do that we all want
them to be happy
i just think those are such big things i
think they should be on the same page
about doing them right right
right let me know in the comments below
i'm gonna get back to my coffee because
i need it and i love you so much bye
last night was so much fun oh but it's
all still wild back to tasha
and tasha is journaling too i thought
this was just a thing we were doing with
claire
is everyone journaling are we all out
there journaling and i didn't know
should i be journaling let me know in
the comments below
and we're getting back to our normal
show now so the guys get a group date
first date card is right here
and it does feel a little familiar oh
boy
the presence of claire and her season
are still being felt we did strip
dodgeball with claire
claire how's the view over there how you
doing now we're doing
speedo slash ball with tasha
tasha's splash ball spectacular but like
many things now that tasha is here this
isn't feeling
quite as controversial as the strip
dodge ball did when dodgeball has
stripped down and walked home
naked it's not happening tonight what
did you think
let me know in the comments below
although we do have underwater cameras
oh wow
and somebody gave chris harrison a
whistle again
but while some of this does seem
familiar i will not be making all those
balls jokes this time
but the blue balls team wins big win
blue team
we really dominated and they get a
barbecue
and an open bar as a prize
an incredible barbecue open bar time
with tasha
so the green team has to head home but i
do feel as though
they know that these guys have been a
bit traumatized
you know um tasha is telling them don't
worry
this isn't even goodbye i'm gonna see
you guys later i got you
i love you i got you guys don't you
worry all right guys
head on out all right so cheers to the
night portion of the group date and
everybody being there and everybody
feeling good and things feeling easy
like we're here with easy
and oh then i get a little uneasy
because easy tells claire
i feel like i just met my wife
like i i feel like i just met my wife
and like i feel like
he says this could be a crazy love story
you know this could be
a crazy love story in the pandemic
in 2020 this was literally this crazy
pandemic in 2020 like
maybe this was all meant to be oh and
easy no
keep it easy don't make it hard this is
too familiar
we do not read claire 2.0
right we had it it's great we're happy
for them i don't i
don't need that again i need something
different now
right
but tasha is giving us different things
she's not saying the same guy's name
over and over again
dale i miss saying it i do i couldn't
totally tell who
she was totally into right away could
you let me know in the comments below
what do you want to know lay it on me
because then she goes from easy to zach
and zack's somebody i hadn't noticed
before but he was pretty funny and cute
on the group date i thought
let's go and tasha are talking
and they're holding hands oh and they're
kissing hi zach
she doesn't want a boy and zack feels
like a man what do we think of zack
i don't want to like teach him how to be
a man you know
well the good news is i think that like
i know what i have to offer i believe
like experience is our greatest teacher
now the guys are confronting our first
rose getter spencer
about his uh douchiness and we are
learning that again
kenny is our forever voice of reason he
says
let me boil it down for you you're
you kind of come off like a
spencer says he didn't know he was being
that way
i didn't even know i had honestly had no
idea that well that's a lie
i mean like you were stirring it a
little bit but i don't know
if i believe him did you let me know in
the comments below because he also very
quickly says that tasha is his
and i quote primary objective
taisha is the primary objective
uh spencer what are your other
objectives what's the secondary one
oh why are you here
look we're like starting a whole new
season tonight we gotta have a villain
tasia is the primary objective
now then riley gives another lesson
riley tells spencer that he is lunch
meat
then when we come across guys like you
we call you lunch meat okay then he says
he
is fried baloney
that made his fried bologna with
mayonnaise i made his fried bologna
sandwich with the mayonnaise all day
because he likes to
i talk a lot of okay
because you like to talk a lot
let me know in the comments below i
don't know easy i want to say thank you
to you as well
because um a conversation you really
opened up to me but it doesn't matter
easy gets the rose
easy would you accept this rose and easy
says that maybe
he's living the greatest love story ever
right now
everything is literally falling into
place and the greatest love story ever
like maybe i'm living it right now would
beg to differ okay
how he makes me feel is literally like
sunbeams out of my heart
like into the world and speaking of you
know claire really
isn't totally gone jason reveals that he
fell in love with claire and i think i
fell in love with
claire so he says he's gotta go
unfortunately i can't do this anymore
and i will say remember
jason's the guy who went on that like
really deep desert therapy
date with claire the triple d and if
anyone's traumatized from all this
i think it's jason what do you think and
i tip my hat to jason tell me what you
thought of his exit but
he said goodbye and told tasha look this
doesn't mean those other guys aren't
here for you
don't let this shake you they're here
for you they're not here for claire
you're such a sweetheart promise if
you're in good hands we're one of those
guys
i do think that claire had a lot of good
guys on her season cheers to jason
and speaking of one-on-ones it's time
for one
tasha's first i definitely need the
reassurance
of knowing that brendan is focused on me
tasia's first one-on-one is the cute
curly hair dude
who i have learned is named brendan
[Music]
you know i've been in here for a couple
weeks but i feel like
this is kind of my first day here and
and you guys
you guys guys
i think i have a girl crush on tasha
she comes in on this horse and she just
looks
gorgeous she's in one of my favorite
looks a white button-up with a
fabulous hat she's even pulling two
horses
facial looks amazing tay mason
do you have a girl crush on tasha let me
know in the comments below
and you know who does agree with me for
sure
of course then she came in on that horse
[Music]
i mean wow she is looking stunning
but from bennett to brendan
and chris harrison hey there
yes chris harrison is back interrupting
their date again
but he does it with good reason he does
it
with a beverage can i interest you in
the famous harrison margarita
he does it bringing them the famous
harrison
margarita and while that is not really a
thing i will tell you guys that chris
harrison makes a good tequila drink
oh and he is running and we have not
seen him move at a speed faster than a
walk since the fence jumped he just
jumped the
fence but even that was a slow jog why
is he running oh no he is on a scooter
he is going going moving and he is
bringing them
more beverages gold coconuts
look who it is i love a beverage and a
snack on a date i love when we do dates
like this
yes breath of fresh
[Music]
but he does finally leave and uh this
date turns into such a meaningful
evening they are kissing in the pool it
is nice and easy
but then but then but then
tasha says she is ready to go home with
him he is everything
because i am ready to go home with this
man i'm i'm telling you right now
brendan is everything and i realized
maybe i'm a little traumatized i don't
want to hear her saying these things
i don't want taysha to make a decision
too quickly i want
a whole season oh but i don't think
she's doing i don't need to be okay i
think they've got us the gift keeps on
giving anything goddess they are at the
dinner portion and brandon is opening up
to tasha
about getting married too young about
getting divorced
in my early 20s i i did get married
we really you know fell out of love and
we remember
tasha went through a similar situation i
actually got married at a young age too
so i could really see her listening and
understanding
and i just thought it was a wonderful
conversation what did you guys think let
me know in the comments below
all in all a very lovely first
one-on-one i adored brendan's sweetness
his honesty what did you think of their
connection let me know in the comments
below
oh god again she feels like she's
kissing her person like she could marry
him kissing brendan
feels like i'm kissing my person oh god
help me help me
help me help
me
breath afresh
oh i sound like voldemort scary okay
harry potter
but no do not worry they're taking care
of us
it's far from over drama is coming we
get the teaser things are happening
all hail is breaking loose you're a
fraud you're phony
that guy this season is very much the
gift
that keeps on giving
oh everybody i am just so unbelievably
pleased with the television that we're
getting
i love you guys so much thank you for
watching and we will of course be back
next week if you want to talk to me in
the meantime i am available on instagram
tick tock twitter and if you want a
personal message from me
on the app cameo i raise the glass to
you
and to the breath of fresh that is tasha
bye i think bennett would like the swine
i do i think it would be up to his
stanford so
harry potter is dead
i gotta stop
[Music]
[Music]